- Oh god it's bad!
- (muffled yelling)
- Radioactive Iguana sounds
like a really bad band name.
- Oh I like that one!
- Mmm!
- It's like standard Tabasco.
- The saltine is good!
- I'm more upset that I
ate the whole saltine.
Ghost in the Darkness Hot Sauce. (laughs)
- Oh god I'm so scared of
putting this in my mouth.
- There's a big (bleeped) tiger.
- He does not look happy.
- It smells like salsa.
But it does kind of like
scratch a little bit more
like it's more painful than the other one.
- But I mean it's sweet
it's good I like this one.
- Yeah
- I think I like this one more.
- Belizean, believe in that heat!
- The letters are literally on fire.
- And it has a heart.
- Well this doesn't look too bad.
- Cheers
- You're going for it.
- Here goes nothin.
- Mmhmm
- (laughing)
- My throat is getting...
I think my teeth are hurting.
- I just felt my sinuses
clear a little bit.
- Oooh, Scorpion!
- Wow
- From Trinidad.
I know people from Trinidad
and they do not (bleep) around.
- And it has a scorpion
tail on it so it'll get ya.
- I feel like my tongue
is going to fall off
- I feel like this one isn't as bad, yet.
- Back of my throat! I put
it in the back of my throat!
(panting)
- What?
- Uh.
- (bleep) you.
- Are you (bleeped) serious?
- Warning, less than
one drop of this product
is absolutely and extremely seriously hot.
- (bleeped) me.
- Flashbang!
- Nope, nope, nope!
- Oh, what is this?
- Oh my god
- (laughing)
- Oh god damn this is getting...
This is a spice level that
I've never felt before.
- Oh no! Ah!
It's going, it's traveling up my nose!
How is this possible?
- I'm sweating.
- No!
- Rest in peace Mia Moses.
(laughing)
- I'm dying.
- Imagine when it gets to the butt hole
how much it's going to burn.
- I don't wanna think about
a couple hours from now.